hey everyone its erik from Fandango I am
here on the set of one of the most
anticipated family movies playing with
fire co-starring this gentleman
keegan-michael key and this is a film
that's got humour it's got heart
it's got action-adventure we might what
am i leaving out uh let me see you
action-adventure comedy comedy it's got
lots and lots of different kinds of
comedy it's got physical comedy
it's got slapstick Carnaby it's got
wordplay it's got everything in it yeah
all right we're gonna go take a look at
some of the film and then we're to come
back and talk about it gentlemen we are
smokejumpers the most elite team of
firefighters in the world we must be at
our very best
so John you've done family movies before
but this feels different a lot of
physical comedy it's silly there's also
a lot of heart what was it about the
story that hooked you
oh it's a good tale and I think that's
to me it didn't I've been in family
stuff I've been more adult stuff I've
been animated stuff in action stuff I've
been drama stuff I think that the common
thread between all that material is I
enjoyed the story and this was no
different I just enjoyed the the voyage
of the kids and the smokejumpers and the
whole movie of it all and I think it's
gonna really play out well on screen
tell me about smokejumpers I'm kind of
obsessed with that job because it's like
this extra level of firefighter there's
the firefighter then you're parachuting
in what's something that that you
learned about this career did you meet
smokejumper so I learned that I could
never do this in my entire life I'm not
gonna tell you like oh we want to train
with the smokejumpers for a week or for
a month first of all you have to have
all the outstanding qualities of a
firefighter which by in itself is one of
extreme merit and then you have to be
brave enough to jump out of a plane and
or a helicopter into a natural disaster
and they jump in with so much gear
because when they land they fight the
fire until the fire is done so they jump
in with all food all supplies all
firefighting gear with their chute with
a backup chute all the equipment not not
to get singed by the inferno and then
they fight the fire and a lot of the the
jumps are at Heights where they will get
severely injured dislocate joints break
bones their co-workers or fellow smoke
jumpers will set the bones or reset the
joint in the field and they'll continue
to fight the fire so we wanted to make a
scenario that would take these real
elite badass sort of characters that you
feel have everything like laser-focused
and figured out and throw their world
into upheaval and I think smoke jumpers
were perfect to do that and they were so
grateful to allow a and Ian and all of
our producers to kind of use their
platform to tell that story but it
really when you watch the beginning of
the movie you see you see us work like
the well-oiled machine that smokejumpers
are you get to feeling like man these
guys got it all figured out there's
nothing that can go wrong and that sets
the stage for a great movie so I said
why the kids yeah so they just it
allowed for a wonderful backdrop a lot
of the movie
is here and a lot of the comedy is
between the kids and the smokejumpers
there are moments where we paint the
smokejumpers in the light that they
deserve
but the story is more about the people
rather than the professional but we can
get you back to your parents I'm legally
bound to take care of you so that's what
I'm gonna do an intern you're gonna feel
beating it's a we can do our job I mean
you do this when you go like oh like
that it's not helpful tell me about your
character who do you play and how does
he fit into the movie so I play a
gentleman by the name of Captain Mark
Rogers and I am second get in command to
superintendent Jake Carson who's played
by John Cena and he's kind of that he's
kind of the supply guy he makes sure
everybody has what they need everything
like the groceries and the equipment
that they use when they go into the
fires he's kind of the shepherd of the
of the group and and that's and that's
something he takes pride in also is that
being there with the right thing
whatever you need in the moment and so
and then he's just kind of he's kind of
he's uh one could say he's a glorified
gofer I would just say he's a person who
loves to help yeah smokejumpers I think
I have a really cool job because not
just they don't just fight fires but
they like parachute it yeah the thing is
but they primarily do is they find a
fire that's starting in a forest and if
we're a forested area they jump out of
fixed-wing aircraft parachute into the
fire and sometimes they'll spend two to
three days there so they'll have about a
hundred and fifty pounds of equipment on
them like where they're gonna you know
what they're gonna eat changes of
clothes all of their equipment and then
what happens it's they shove the
equipment out of the plane the rest of
the equipment falls next to them they
open it up and then they start and it's
very very heavy manual labor and we've
we've done some of it we're just like
anytime you want to call cut Andy
anytime you wanna cut you're raking and
shoveling and making ditches and it's
crazy
yeah and in the midst of all this you
guys kind of come across some kids
you're taking care of kids and that's
sort of the move now it's the catalyst
to get us into the rest of the yeah
we're kind of on an emergency call which
is pretty routine for smokejumpers and
they go and they save these three kids
that are siblings and we can't find the
parents we don't know where the parents
are and so we're stuck taking care of
them so it's pretty much it's pretty
much back draft meets three men and a
baby
you play one of the smokejumpers in the
film how does your character sort of
factor into this unconventional family
that we're seeing well it's it's mad
unconventional that that's for sure you
hit the you hit the right word cuz it's
John Cena keegan-michael key and Tyler
who's like 7-foot tall these four guys
become like you know mr. mom's for mr.
mom's taking care these three kids and
we're all like mismatched dysfunctional
it's a perfect recipe for mayhem yeah I
mean you are a veteran performer what
was it about this story this movie that
maybe spoke to you that maybe there's
something that you saw in it that you
hadn't done yet in your career well it
was actually John Cena and Keegan that
made me want to do this cuz I've been
hangin with Killian in New York and
having such a blast with him and John
Cena and I did sisters and I had so much
fun with him that I was like I want to
hang out with them for two months and
have a good time that's really what sold
me I feel like the smokejumpers is it's
such a fascinating job like I was trying
to think of like movies that have
featured smokejumpers I can't even think
of one no one's ever done it I mean
they're real heroes I mean I feel lucky
that they let me play this role you know
I mean because these are real American
heroes who go out there and risk their
lives and and save save many lives and
save forests I mean it's a crazy job to
jump out of a plane into a burning
raging forest fire under my watch
we buy your man can't turn my neck
Rihanna tell me a little bit about this
film who do you play in it I play a
character named Brynn and she is 16
she's been taking care of her two
siblings for like two years now and she
basically acts as the mother to them
they're kind of abandoned and then these
smokejumpers find them and have to deal
with them have to figure out how to take
care of them
and speaking of dealing you're working
with John Cena John Leguizamo
keegan-michael key and it seems just
it's like it's there's a really great
vibe it's fun it's friendly it's goofy
what's that been like it's been really
fun it's been a good time especially
like the mixture of the kids and adults
it kind of it kind of cleans up
everyone's humor and their act which is
I don't know it makes things more goofy
and a little more silly on set so it's
been really cool and I just feel honored
to be working with like such seasoned
actors at this point you know you've
done the superhero movie you've done
kind of the crazy horror genre movie
like what boxes is tick off for you in
terms of your career and what you
haven't done yet that you're getting to
experience now yeah this is like a like
a fun family comedy which is something
that I've never done and there's also a
lot of like physical comedy which is
stuff that I've never delved into so
it's been really fun it's been an
experience
you know the vibe being here on this set
has been so much fun it seems like you
guys are having a lot of fun what's been
the highlight for you making this film
so far the highlight making this film
would be all the stunts and the amazing
cast and crew and all the cool stunts
and scenes I get to do oh yeah I mean
you have John Cena John Leguizamo
keegan-michael key these are all really
funny guys so has that been just a real
great time just working with those guys
and getting to know them it's been
amazing working with them do you have
like a favorite moment or a favorite
scene that you're in the scene where
were in a Humvee or trying to escape
from Jake aka John Cena because we're
scared that he's been the cultural
protective services and we just want to
escape and get away from the depot so we
get into a car accident and then our car
spins and then ends up half the car on
the edge of the cliff half the car on
land you'll have to see the movie to
find out how that scene ends so Jake
this is so Christian tell the audience
at home especially kids who are going to
want to go see this movie what are the
kids out there need to know about this
movie that's gonna make them really want
to go see it so the kids out there
really need to know that there's gonna
be insane stunts and it's gonna be a
very good movie the best and there's
gonna be so many funny moments and like
keegan-michael key he he just comes up
with anything and then everybody laughs
on set the same for John Leguizamo and
John Cena and everyone on set
well now it's a party you're sort of in
the middle of keegan-michael key and
John Leguizamo these guys are like
masters at improv so you know what did
they teach you how to flex like your
comedic muscles in different ways like
what's something cool that you learned
about me yeah I enjoy trying to trying
to get in that mix I try to learn from
every experience my character is
essentially the straight and forward
law-abiding law making head of the Depot
so it's not in what I'm trying to do to
improvise so what I learned is like you
have to know what you're doing in the
movie never just try to be a part of
something that you think is fun but
won't be funny in the movie and a lot of
the physical comedy bounces off of me
because I'm supposed to be the guy who's
always looking perfect so while they're
going back and forth and jokes I'm
getting covered in poop and soap suds
and motor oil and like it's a disaster
so I have my spots to be funny
but I think the thing I learned most
from them especially when they go on
these unbelievable riffs that are gonna
make the movie gold is to never like a
good improv person never breaks the
improv scenario and in the improv
scenario I'm serious and they're foolish
so it literally is just me going like
this most of the time because their
stuff is just hilarious but even in
their performances I can take a bunch of
stuff but it's actually a really good
lesson about like know your character
don't deviate from your character
because although you want to have a fun
time it hurt the movie yeah if there's
one thing you want audiences to know
about this film as they're sort of
deciding what they want to watch what's
something they want to know they should
know about it before they watch movies
are entertaining this movie is going to
be entertaining and the great thing
about playing with fire is it casts a
wide net
you're going to be able to bring your
kids and they're going to laugh because
there's poopy stuff and soapy stuff and
slipping and falling but you're gonna
actually go to the theater as a parent
and have a great time - the story has
wonderful heart it's all connected so
very well like everyone's performance is
outstanding from John to Keegan to Judy
to Tyler
- Christian to Finley I'm giving you the
whole cast - Briana like everyone has
stepped up and we've made something
great here so I think it's what I want
everybody to know is I think it's gonna
take they entertain a lot of audiences
[Music]
what just happened I think the baby just
broke it dogs whoo
what's something that you want the
audience at home to know about this film
before they watch it oh they're gonna
love the comedy bits ma'am we're having
so much fun creating like Buster Keaton
Peter Sellers type humor you know the
banter between Keegan and I we hit it
off on camera off camera I think they're
gonna love all those moments the great
action the physical action silly moments
I mean we're really trying to pilot in
yeah I feel like this is a kind of
throwback sort of family movie it's an
original movie that we don't see that
much these than us like three minute a
little babies yeah the kind of kind of
John Hughes made you know that dad you
could take the from 8 to 80 they call
them these movies you know you can bring
everybody nobody's offended everybody
leaves feeling good and you know it's a
it's a good time for everybody don't do
it run with it
it feels like a throwback to the kind of
family movies that we used to see like a
couple of decades ago yeah it feels like
it has a similar feeling like home alone
you know the kids are really cute but
there's lots of physical comedy with the
adults and the kids and you're gonna see
through this really fun look hilarious
set pieces in this thing that we've
spent a lot of time and a lot of effort
on and I'm really looking forward to
seeing them how they come together
because you're right it has a vintage
feel to it and it's it's got a nice open
fun energy to it that we don't see as
much anymore so if there's one thing
audiences need to know about this movie
before they go see it what is that thing
I think the biggest thing is how the
heart of the film is gonna sneak up on
you there's really great themes about
family what a family is what's the
makeup of a family you know we have so
many different kinds of families these
days that are different than the nuclear
family and I think that you're gonna see
that a lot in the film but then also I
think the way that Andy fickman our
director who's just amazing works so
well with kids you got everything here
we had animals we got kids we got we got
wrestlers we've got comedic actors we've
people who've won Tony's we got people
who won Emmys we got everything in this
thing but I think that the the hearts
really gonna sneak up on people people
gonna be pleasantly surprised in in
addition to how crazy the comedy is
gonna be Andy's done Andy's done a real
a real heck of a balancing act getting
all of this into the movie yeah well you
heard it here and then when they go and
they listen to this and they want to get
their tickets where do they go you go to
fin tango easiest place online to get
your movie tickets I've been doing it
for I mean not that I'm that old but
I've been doing it for 15 years it's
that possible that's possible is
possible yeah yeah yes 15 years I've
been getting tickets from Fandango for
15 years
you